♪ ♪
ALEX: When I was a kid,
I didn't do very good in school,
and, uh, my dad would
always try to,
I guess, get me thinking about
my future, what I wanted to do.
You know,
he would just ask me, like,
"What do you wanna be
when you grow up," you know?
I always told him that
I wanted to be a caveman.
I didn't wanna be an engineer.
I didn't wanna be a doctor.
Didn't wanna be an astronaut.
I wanted to be a caveman.
So making a fire here
in this extremely
primitive shelter,
I kind of feel like
I'm living my childhood dream.
♪ ♪
Mother Nature is
setting the rules,
and all I got to do is find
a way to play her game.
♪ ♪
I'm just getting packed up,
ready to go.
I got some food,
stuff to cook with,
fire-starting stuff.
Just got enough essentials
to keep me comfortable
while I'm there.
Well, to keep me alive
I wouldn't say comfortable.
This will be my first night
in the primitive shelter,
and I don't know
how cold it'll get.
I'm headed out to go
beaver hunting today.
I've never hunted them before.
The reason I specifically
am targeting beavers
is because they're basically
the largest animal
that's legal for me to hunt
this time of year.
It's a pretty fatty animal,
so it's a pretty,
pretty rich calorie source.
My hunting cabin is basically
at the halfway point
between my old cabin
and the hunting grounds.
It basically is just a place
I can stop, get dry, get warm,
cook a dinner,
and not freeze to death.
♪ ♪
KALEB: We can just
walk out our door
and we're out
in the great outdoors,
enjoying nature,
breathing fresh, clean,
non-polluted air.
And I think that's just
a great way to live life.
♪ ♪
You can follow me.
BRITTANY: Okay.
NARRATOR: Isolated in the small
community of McCarthy, Alaska,
Brittany and Kaleb Rowland
have chosen to raise their kids
away from the hustle
of a major city.
But with limited stores
in town,
they'll need to travel over 300
miles along a dangerous highway
to get much-needed
building supplies.
And in order to make
the most of their trip,
they never leave
with an empty trailer.
KALEB: Brittany and I
are gonna be heading over
to this junk vehicle that's
sitting out on the river bar.
And we're gonna load it up
on the trailer
and haul it into town.
BRITTANY: Over the last couple
years, one of Kaleb's goals
has been to get all of the old
clunkers out of McCarthy.
So I drive the forklift while
Kaleb does the heavy lifting
and any of the dirty stuff.
KALEB: My turn.
I'm gonna pick up
that yellow vehicle there
and load it on the trailer
and strap it down,
and we'll get out of here.
BRITTANY: Kaleb does this
several times a year.
It's really an act of love
for the community.
KALEB: We live in the middle
of the world's largest
national park,
and people come out here
and pay thousands
and thousands of dollars
to see the pristine wilderness,
and junk vehicles really
don't need to be a part of that.
And so I try to get them off
to the recycling center
so that they will, hopefully,
someday be turned
into a new vehicle again.
♪ ♪
Looks like the clouds
are rolling in.
The weather might be changing,
so we need to get the heck out
of here to get to Anchorage.
The road is pretty tricky.
We're getting into wintertime.
There's ice, potholes,
road glaciers, animals.
You have to have
your wits about you.
BRITTANY: Think it'll hold?
KALEB: Looking good. I think
that'll stay on my trailer.
Let's hit the road.
BRITTANY: Cool.
MICHAEL: If you don't
challenge yourself,
if you don't push
out of your comfort zone,
you're not gonna grow
to the extent that you could.
All these sleds that I have,
they should be turned
into flower pots.
Most of my sleds are breaking,
and they're all these,
these traditional
cordage-lashed,
mortise-and-tenon joint
kind of sleds.
That thing is done.
My bread-and-butter sled.
I've hauled a lot of fish and
lot of caribou with this sled.
And it's worked hard.
It's been, it's been worn out.
But it's time to, to build one
that will hold up
to these malamutes.
They destroy everything.
A half a decade
of running these dogs...
(bleep)
...I realize that
they're just totally brutal
on whatever I hook to them.
Hey, hey, hey, hey!
The force that they exert
is just too much
for the typical way
that sleds are built.
So now it's time to take matters
into my own hands
and build a good sled.
Most sleds have been designed
exclusively for sport, racing.
And that kind of stuff,
that doesn't fly in my world,
because I got work to do.
Hunting, fishing,
hauling firewood.
So this is a first.
This is the first sled
I will have ever built,
and it has to pass
a lot of tests.
These are the makings
of my runners.
These are a little bit thicker
than quarter-inch-long strips.
They are 14 foot long.
And it'll be a real flexible
runner, too, when I'm done.
You want the sled
to give and flex.
And if that thing
ain't flexible,
if that thing ain't strong,
that thing is gonna be
destroyed by these dogs.
♪ ♪
You know, as I'm putting
the sled together,
I've been taking
a few little moments
to pause and think about
the people I come from.
And I was reading a book
that my grandmother was in
called
Our Lives Are in Our Hands,
and she made a lot
of amazing things.
Whether it was pack baskets,
fishing creels, axe handles,
hockey sticks, snowshoes,
she made really strong,
flexible stuff.
And the book
Our Lives Are in Our Hands
got a lot of meaning for me
as I continue on the tradition
of building traditional things,
whether they're canoes
or whether they're dog sleds.
It's really in my blood.
♪ ♪
Whoa, that's a big sled.
This thing is
11 and a half foot long.
This is a real freight sled.
This thing is built to haul
a load of caribou,
firewood, fish, lots of gear
on an expedition.
You name it,
this thing will swallow it.
But it's super flexible.
Even the runners.
But this thing is done, and
I need to catch up on some rest,
wake up in the morning,
hook these dogs up,
and give this thing
a maiden voyage.
♪ ♪
JESSI: Self-reliance,
you know, it's freedom.
That's what it is.
♪ ♪
(engine sputters)
CHRIS: My throttle's all stuck.
Hey, Jess, can you grab me
the blowtorch?
I think my throttle's
all iced up.
Machines are really
important out here.
You got to take care of them.
If you don't treat
your machine well,
it's not gonna work well
and it's not gonna make it
through the winter.
JESSI: What's going on?
CHRIS: Uh, the throttle's
all froze up on here.
It's not moving.
JESSI: Oh.
This freezing rain sucks.
CHRIS: Yeah, I mean, I'm gonna
try to warm it up a little bit.
See if I can just
get it to let go.
Hopefully, I can just
thaw it out real quick
and I don't have to disassemble
the whole thing.
We got really short days
out here,
and I don't wanna spend
half my day
wrenching on my three-wheeler.
You can see it's still frozen.
So that means I got to dig
into it a little bit more.
JESSI: You know, there wouldn't
be any ice in the line
if we had a shed
to keep this in.
CHRIS: Yeah.
If this three-wheeler was
just stored inside of a shed,
it wouldn't have got covered
in freezing rain,
and I wouldn't be out here
spending my precious daylight
wrenching on it again.
I just got to get
this shed built.
NARRATOR: At their isolated,
remote homestead,
Chris and Jessi Morse rely on
what little equipment they have
in order to survive.
With darkness and cold coming,
it's crucial their machinery
remains functional.
JESSI: This is some icy stuff
up here, huh?
CHRIS: Yeah, be careful.
JESSI: Well, hi, Toz.
You don't seem to mind, do you?
CHRIS: Alright, so let's see,
that's, that's almost six feet.
Seven feet's probably
all we need.
(chainsaw revving)
♪ ♪
I figure we need about ten logs
in total to build the shed.
We'll do three or four at a time
until we get them all.
Oof!
Wow, that thing's heavy.
I don't know if I can move that.
JESSI: We need to go back
and get the sled,
and you put the front part
in the sled.
CHRIS: Yeah. I can get that
small, black, skinny sled.
JESSI: You wanna run back now
or you wanna try it?
I mean, I can cut the next log.
CHRIS: Yeah, cut it,
and I'll, I'll drag this.
JESSI: Okay.
(chainsaw revving)
I have cut my fair share of wood
in this exact area
with this exact saw.
So, uh, pretty comfortable in
the wood yard with a chainsaw.
(bleep)
Got it stuck. (laughs)
That's what I get for saying
I've done this before.
(revving)
(chainsaw stops)
(bleep)
JESSI: I really don't
wanna break this.
Damn.
(laughs) Oh, my gosh!
I got this.
I know what I'm doing.
Ha! What a crock.
♪ ♪
So don't get mad.
I got the chainsaw stuck.
CHRIS: Hopefully not underneath.
JESSI: Definitely underneath.
CHRIS: We don't have
another one, so.
JESSI: Can you just come over
here and give me a hand?
I didn't wanna pinch up top.
Anyways, doesn't matter.
I did it wrong.
♪ ♪
Thanks.
So we had to lift and then pull,
and I just couldn't.
Wonderful.
CHRIS: We're really far
out here,
we don't have neighbors
for miles and miles,
so we really got
to work together
and not get mad at each other
and work as a team.
Nice.
Yeah, I'm gonna go
load that log.
Um, go ahead
and cut this one off.
JESSI: Okay.
CHRIS: And then just keep doing
exactly what you're doing,
and I'll keep moving logs.
JESSI: Okay.
♪ ♪
Chris and I are
a really good team.
I'm just stoked for our project.
CHRIS: I finally feel like
we're settling in
and I'm getting the hang
of the work program out here,
hauling water, hauling wood,
working all day long till dark
and then working a little more.
♪ ♪
This is a chainsaw mill.
This is my first time
using a log mill.
I have planed
a lot of boards by hand,
but they don't come out
very smooth.
This device right here should
make my bar and my chain
last a lot longer.
♪ ♪
Ha ha! Let's see what
it looks like, huh?
JESSI: Maybe too thin, huh?
CHRIS: Yeah.
JESSI: I mean, but I, eee,
that's a little thin, love.
I think a...
CHRIS: A little bit thicker?
JESSI: ...300-pound bear
will snap right through that.
CHRIS: Yeah. You know.
JESSI: One more time.
♪ ♪
(revving)
CHRIS: I don't really know
what I'm doing.
I'm not a carpenter
by any means.
I've been a mechanic
and a welder my whole life,
uh, so building with wood is
a little bit out of my element.
I'm learning and
making things work better.
Alright.
Now, that's a nice board.
JESSI: That's our first
perfect board!
CHRIS: Looks cool.
Good job.
Alright, now, uh, 40 more?
JESSI: I was gonna say 75 more.
Let's get a-millin'.
♪ ♪
ALEX: Yeah, I really savor
my alone time out here.
It's, uh, it's not the same
as alone time in the city,
because there's always noises
and distractions and smell.
You know what I mean? There's
things you don't even notice.
You basically, you basically
can't get quiet time
in the city.
Today I'm going in there
with the intent to beaver hunt.
This is the same area
I used to hunt moose at.
There was always a couple
beavers in it, swimming around.
And then in the middle,
they have their dam.
I'm looking for signs of beaver.
That would be either
tracks in the snow
or recently chewed-down trees.
That would indicate that beavers
are still operating
in this area.
This is the sign
of a wild beaver.
Beavers chew down trees.
That's how they build
their dams.
The beaver dam's
just right here.
I'm just gonna
take a look around,
see if I see tracks,
signs of activity.
♪ ♪
Kind of doesn't seem like
there's any beavers here.
I don't see any tracks around.
They may have gone.
It's getting
pretty dark, though,
so it might be good
to head home soon.
♪ ♪
BRITTANY: Some of the benefits
of living this lifestyle
is you really value
what you have.
♪ ♪
KALEB: It's about
a six-hour, one-way trip
without the trailer.
And with the trailer
on this trip,
it'll be about eight hours.
It's quite the ordeal.
And all of that
on icy, nasty roads.
♪ ♪
BRITTANY: You have to be
very sure of yourself
and your vehicle to drive
the road in winter.
The first thing we have to do
is drive 60 miles of dirt road.
The McCarthy dirt road is
not for the faint of heart.
We never know what's
around the next corner.
KALEB: We're making first tracks
down the road right now
since it snowed last.
BRITTANY: Kaleb knows
the McCarthy Road very well,
but in winter months,
things change so drastically.
♪ ♪
Where's the road glaciers?
KALEB: They're for the next
30 miles or so.
BRITTANY: Okay.
KALEB: It is very much
like running a gauntlet
to get out of here
and into town.
You really have to want it.
There's road glaciers
where water flows across
the road and freezes.
Some of them can get
10, 12 feet thick.
That gets downright scary.
There's one in particular
that's bigger than all the rest,
and we will be stopping
and checking it
before we cross it
to make sure it's not too bumpy.
And hopefully this little bit
of snow that's on the road
doesn't mask it
where we can't see it.
That would be very dangerous.
BRITTANY: Oh.
The joys of this road.
KALEB: I'm kind of wondering
if we won't even see anybody
on the road here.
So if we get into trouble
in any way,
we're completely on our own.
Cell phone service along
the road is hit or miss.
You have to be dedicated
to travel that road.
You have to know
how get yourself
out of situations without help.
It is quite common to travel
the entire length
of the McCarthy Road
without seeing a single person.
♪ ♪
BRITTANY: Okay. Whoa. Whoa.
KALEB: Well, here we go.
Here's our road glacier.
Thank god for trailer brakes.
Ah.
♪ ♪
Alright, so I,
when I check these out,
I walk up on the high side here
and just kind of feel
how slippery it is.
And I look for this,
this is some slush here,
which gives good traction.
So if I've got slush,
we're pretty much good to go.
BRITTANY:
Think we'll make it across?
KALEB: Let's give her a go.
♪ ♪
Oh, that one was good.
BRITTANY: Do you think those
are gonna get worse?
KALEB: Oh, they're gonna
get much worse.
We're at the beginning
of the winter right now.
They've only just
started to form.
Right here is
the Kuskulana Bridge.
It's 256 feet up above
the river bottom.
♪ ♪
We've made it through the
toughest part of the road here.
All the road glaciers
and potholes are behind us,
so now it's pretty much just
smooth sailing on into the city.
I'm hoping to spend as little
amount of time in the city
as possible tomorrow,
so we need to be quick and
efficient in all our stops.
I really dislike
going into the city.
It's always stressful for me.
And I'm always just wanting
to get in and get out.
BRITTANY:
We are in the city! Woo-hoo!
KALEB: Oh, boy.
♪ ♪
CHRIS: We're always trying
to look ahead as far as we can,
and long-term goals out here
are great to have,
but sometimes you just have to
focus on what's in front of you.
(chainsaw roaring)
Hey, Jess, how many boards
do we have?
JESSI: 22, 23, 24, 25.
CHRIS:
We're right on the money, 25.
JESSI: 25.
CHRIS: We're gonna get
a few more out of this
and we'll be done.
JESSI: Yeah!
CHRIS: My dad built this cabin
and left it to me.
And I haven't had a chance
to come out here
and really build any structures.
Once I get this structure done,
I'm gonna feel like I have
accomplished something out here,
and I've adding something
to the homestead.
That's gonna feel good.
JESSI: Yes!
Last cut, love.
Last one!
Yes!
Ready to build shed!
Okay.
CHRIS: So what we need is
about 12-foot-long birch poles
that are about
four inches in diameter.
We're gonna put those
at the top,
and that's gonna be
the main roof supports.
Followed by a couple
smaller beams going down
to support the planks
that we have made.
Let's see if we can get
about 10 of them.
JESSI: Okay.
CHRIS: Alright.
JESSI: I will haul them back.
CHRIS: It's getting cold out.
JESSI: I know. Winter's coming.
(chainsaw roaring)
♪ ♪
CHRIS: When you're
out here building
without a wood supply store,
and you don't have everything,
you just have to build
with what nature gives you.
(grunts)
Watch out!
♪ ♪
The real reason we're using
the trees that are already here
is that they make really good
permanent structures.
They're not gonna heave
with the frost.
They've been here a long time.
I'm not worried about them
caving under the snow load.
This is gonna add
a lot of structure
having these extra trees.
JESSI: I've never built anything
that I didn't get every single
part from a hardware store.
And we made that
pumper out here.
And, you know, most of
those nails were burned out
from who knows when.
JESSI: There we go.
CHRIS: Nice!
CHRIS: Our next step here
is we're gonna start
putting the planks up.
First one there, huh?
So, Jess, take a look at this.
I'm gonna put you in charge
of drilling holes,
and I'm gonna hammer nails.
(drilling)
Alright.
You know, I didn't really know
what I was building
when I started.
I knew the general idea,
I wanted a triangle shed.
As I go along, I just take it as
it is and build with what I got.
Nice!
JESSI: Yeah, shed! Yes!
CHRIS: Coming along.
You know, my dad handmade
this cabin with no power tools.
Just a hand whip and a hammer.
He didn't have the tools
to make a perfect house,
but that's okay;
he built a home.
You're not gonna
always do it right;
just keep trying.
He always told me that.
My dad moved out to the bush
when he was about 19.
And here I am in my 30s
moving out to the bush.
That's when he came
out of the bush,
which kind of makes me feel
like I'm just picking up
where Dad left off.
Getting out there,
building on the house,
making things work.
I feel like I'm following
in my dad's footsteps.
♪ ♪
MICHAEL: In the long run,
you could pay for convenience,
but sometimes you got to take
things into your own hands
and build it right for you.
(dogs barking)
You better eat your meal.
You got to be
my crash test dummy.
Go ahead.
You ready for a new sled, Snoop?
You ready to break a new sled?
You're not gonna break this one.
You're not gonna break
this sled, big boy.
NARRATOR: In order to hunt
and gather resources,
Michael Manzo has
completed construction
on a custom freight sled.
But in order to test his work,
he'll need to run it across
the harsh Alaskan terrain.
MICHAEL: Last night, I got the
brunt of this sled build done
well into the evening,
and now it's the test.
I wanna see if it
can actually hold up
to three of my most brutal dogs
in the lot.
Prime, Snoop, and Cyran.
My biggest, most powerful dogs
in the lot.
They're terrible dogs
to get out of the yard,
because they destroy stuff.
I don't approve of the design.
Snoop approves of the design.
(barks)
Wanna go for a run?
(barking)
Dogs are crazy.
It moves so easy.
Look at that.
Look at this.
Moves on a pinkie.
(barking)
That thing is slick.
There's a lot of uncertainty
with running this sled.
It's an entirely new design.
It is a very long sled
in a tight, wooded trail.
It's 11 foot long
from the front of the bow
to the back of the runner,
and that's a little
nerve-racking.
Basket sleds of that length are
synonymous for not steering.
I designed everything
as strongly as I could
and as flexible as I could,
but I'll give it
a good test and see.
Alright. Time to harness
these crazy dogs up.
(barking)
You ready to go for a run,
buddy?
They shred stuff.
They destroy sleds.
They don't care that
that sled is long.
They're just gonna go.
Double-check everything.
Make sure I screwed
these carabiners down,
'cause this is a lot of dog.
These dogs are brutal.
(barking)
Alright.
I got to get these guys on
the trail, they're going crazy.
Go get 'em! Hyah! Hyah! Hyah!
(barking)
MICHAEL: I got to get
these guys on the trail,
they're going crazy.
Go get 'em! Hyah! Hyah! Hyah!
(barking)
Go get 'em! Hyah! Hyah! Haw!
Whoa, whoa. Hey, hey, hey!
Get up there! Come on!
(barking)
Go get 'em! Hyah! Hyah! Hyah!
Come on. Hop up. Hop up. Hyah!
♪ ♪
This is a lot.
Just starting out with a fresh
sled on a tight, wooded trail.
Usually when
you test a sled out,
you'd wanna test it
in the open country,
or on a lake,
or out on the sea ice
where you're not gonna
crash into stuff.
I'm kind of taking it
to another level.
♪ ♪
Wow, that steered good!
Dang!
See that tight corner?
It's taking corners, man.
I can lean into it.
I get a lot of motivation
from this dog team of mine.
They're a really rowdy bunch.
And we're doing new things,
we're going new places,
and we're getting better
with each year.
I've broken a half dozen
different sleds
over the past five years,
but this one here,
it's gonna be a tough sled.
And I can haul way more than
I could ever imagine.
The amount of capability
that I'm gaining
with this sled is insane.
Woo!
It's a fun run!
♪ ♪
ALEX: At the end of the day,
I try to think,
okay, how much time do I have
left before I call this quits?
Before it's going past the point
of diminishing returns?
♪ ♪
Last night, it rained
and got really warm
and everything melted.
This will make finding
tracks of animals,
specifically beavers down there,
probably impossible.
It'll probably be all melted.
But I think I'll still
go down there
and I'll look for any
recently chewed trees.
Yeah, I haven't had a good
protein dinner in a while.
It would be nice, but,
you know, there's lean times
and then there's,
there's non-lean times.
Right now is a lean time, so.
I'm gonna head back out,
looking to see if
I missed anything yesterday,
see if there's
any sign of beaver.
I don't have my fingers crossed
on this, but you never know.
It's always good to
double-check and make sure.
I never paid attention to the
distances out here or the time.
I kind of measure things in
terms of how tired it makes me
or how much effort it takes.
So it can be hard to explain
to other people.
A lot of times people ask me,
"How far is it
from here to here?"
And I say, "Uh, I don't know,
an hour maybe."
But I honestly have no idea.
That's just kind of
what it feels like to me.
But I live out here alone,
so it works for me.
♪ ♪
Well, back here
at the beaver dam.
I think the owners are gone.
I took a look
around the perimeter,
tried to see if I could see any,
like, recently chewed trees.
They all look pretty old.
I think these beavers probably
left a year or more ago.
So beaver's off the menu.
♪ ♪
It's a little disappointing.
Beaver would have been
a great, great meal.
But it is what it is.
I always try to be open
to learning from failure
and not let failure
disappoint me.
(clucking)
(fluttering)
I, uh, I heard grouse wings.
I think he just moved from one
tree over here, over to there.
Grouse, they, they make
a distinctive noise.
As soon as I hear the sound,
I get my eyes up
and just watch and listen.
If you can spot where they are,
usually you can see
where they land
'cause they don't land too far.
They try to rely on their
camouflage to avoid detection.
He's just right ahead of me
in that tree there.
♪ ♪
(gunshot)
ALEX: Yeah.
♪ ♪
Looks like we got him
through the heart.
It's a decent-sized one.
So, uh, there's a nice dinner.
It's pretty awesome.
It's still a good place to hunt.
Even if beavers
are off the table,
it's always good to hunt
different areas.
We'll go ahead and
field dress it here,
because the weather
is pretty is warm,
I don't want the meat
to get spoiled.
So by taking out the guts
and just removing
just the meat you want,
taking off all the feathers,
it'll help the meat
cool down quicker.
Good enough.
I'll just rip out the breast
and the wings.
The rest is just gut piles.
The reason I always take
a backpack full
of what you might call possibles
is because there's
always a possibility
you come across an opportunity
you didn't plan for.
In this case,
I was going to find beavers.
There's no beavers,
so, tough luck there.
But I managed to get
a grouse today.
I can return home happy.
Have a nice dinner tonight.
That's always very encouraging.
♪ ♪
KALEB: While this life
may not be more complicated
than life in the city,
it does require its own
unique set of challenges,
which are usually overcome
with proper planning
and due diligence.
♪ ♪
BRITTANY: So what are we doing
first this morning?
KALEB: So we're dropping the
vehicle off at the scrapyard,
and then we're gonna be headed
to the hardware store,
pick up a load
of building materials.
Definitely ready to have it
off of my trailer
and be done with it.
Alright, we're here.
BRITTANY: Sweet.
KALEB: It feels great getting
this vehicle dropped off
at the junkyard.
It's yet another eyesore
gone from my valley.
So far the weather has been
holding off for us.
However, there's a weather front
moving into
the Copper River Valley.
So we're gonna try and beat
that weather system home.
Alright, we're here.
BRITTANY: Can we get
a nap after this?
KALEB: Um, no.
The lumber supplier
is 300 miles away.
You have to pay attention
and make sure your preparation
is done in advance.
KALEB: Thank you much.
MAN: Alrighty.
KALEB: Somebody will be out
with a forklift?
MAN: Yup.
KALEB: Sweet.
KALEB: I'm picking up
some two-bys, some plywood,
and some other odds and ends
of building materials.
We're gonna put about
7,500 pounds on the trailer.
It'll weigh it down nice.
Should give it lots
of traction on the road.
♪ ♪
Starting to snow a little bit.
BRITTANY: Yeah.
KALEB: Hopefully the roads
will be good.
BRITTANY: How's the weight feel?
Is it any different
from the truck?
KALEB: Oh, it's
a little bit heavier,
but it feels well-distributed,
and it doesn't bounce
when we go over bumps.
BRITTANY: Oh, that's nice.
KALEB: Which feels so much nicer
than the truck.
BRITTANY: Yeah.
That'll be really nice
on our way home.
We have lots of bounces.
KALEB: Lots of bumps.
BRITTANY: Yeah. That's what I...
KALEB: Frost heaves, potholes.
And that's just
on the paved section.
That's not even
the McCarthy Road.
♪ ♪
Dumb light.
BRITTANY: Oh, man.
Aren't you glad
we have none in McCarthy?
KALEB: I am so glad.
Brittney really would
like to stay longer,
but we need to get going home.
BRITTANY: We don't want to get
caught up in the storm.
It sounds like it's gonna be
a pretty bad one with rain,
which is never fun
this time of year.
KALEB: Slippery highways,
here we come.
See you later, city.
♪ ♪
CHRIS: Every time I make a plan,
I have to change it.
So I just like to let
the universe guide me
and just build what I build.
♪ ♪
(hammering)
Alright, love.
JESSI: The roof!
CHRIS: Got a roof!
(grunts)
JESSI: Okay. Look at that!
CHRIS: There it is.
JESSI: Yes!
CHRIS: Good work.
JESSI: Yay, shed!
Let's get that three-wheeler.
Show it its home.
The shed is done.
I am so stoked.
Gallons of sawdust.
My hair and my eyes
will never be the same.
And we're done.
That seems pretty
stinking solid!
CHRIS: I'm not the best
builder in the world,
but the project
came together pretty well.
(engine sputters)
Awesome. Uh--agh!
(engine revving)
(click)
(revving)
JESSI: Yeah!
I love our shed.
I love what it looks like.
I love that it fits
the three-wheeler.
CHRIS: I feel pretty confident
that I did a good job
and it's gonna
withstand the bears.
(grunts)
JESSI: Which side?
CHRIS: Your side first.
JESSI: It's useable,
it's functional, it's beautiful.
Our stuff is gonna be way
more safe when we're not here.
Chris and I did good.
♪ ♪
BRITTANY: I'm glad your parents
could keep the kids
another night;
it's about their bedtime.
KALEB: Uh, yeah.
BRITTANY: We still have
another what? Hour and a half?
KALEB: Still another
30 miles to get home.
BRITTANY: Goodness.
KALEB: So I think
we're gonna put chains
on the two front tires.
Just for safety,
for the rest of the trips.
Can you run the spotlight?
BRITTANY: Yeah.
KALEB: It's a difficult enough
road to travel during the day.
And throwing darkness
into the mix
just makes it that much harder.
I'm ready to get
out of this rain.
Alright. That's nice and tight.
BRITTANY: Alright, well,
let's get out of the wind.
I'm frozen.
♪ ♪
KALEB: We're gonna be super
careful; it's 50 degrees out.
There's slick ice on the road,
and it's raining and blowing.
So we're getting hit
from all sides here.
♪ ♪
ALEX: It's really nice to have
this nature-provided dinner.
Be able to cook it outside
in this nice weather.
This isn't some disgusting,
factory farmed, sickly bird
that had a terrible life.
This was a beautiful,
magnificent creature
of the woods.
It was strong. It was powerful.
It was healthy.
I was there with it
in its final moments.
(sizzling)
I really enjoy quiet solitude
here at the cabin.
And the weather's nice and warm.
Just sit by the stove
and watch the trees grow,
listen to the wind.
♪ ♪
♪ Oh, my lord, take this soul ♪
♪ Lay me at the bottom
of the river ♪
♪ The devil has come
to carry me home ♪
♪ Lay me at the bottom ♪
♪ The bottom of the river ♪
MICHAEL: I felt dead
for a long time
after my three
one-year tours in Iraq,
and I was very frustrated
with the world.
And it took many years
to actually find things
that are passionate and fun.
I really enjoy the journey
of traversing the landscape
by dog team.
It's just, it's a great
breath of fresh air.
Nice catch.
♪ ♪
CHRIS: When my dad moved out
to the Cosna,
it was during the Homestead Act.
There was already
a bunch of homesteaders
up there settled in.
There was a whole
slew of people.
JESSI: Oh, man.
CHRIS: Heavy.
He had a little neighborhood.
He had friends to help him
lift logs onto his cabin.
Those days have passed.
We're pretty much the only
homesteaders out there anymore,
so we got to turn
to each other for help.
And without my wife,
it wouldn't be possible.
We're a team in this.
♪ ♪
BRITTANY: Here we are.
We were only in town
for about 24 hours.
I definitely wish that
we could spend more time there.
I don't know when
the next town trip will be.
But this is really my home,
and I'm really glad to be home.
Man, it's slick!
Can we put some of those chains
on my feet?
KALEB: Good to be home.
(Brittany laughs)
BRITTANY: Very good to be home.
ALEX: If you're gonna
live out here,
you have to kind of have
a mindset of a perpetual growth.
I'll ask a question,
you know, like,
if these trees had something
to teach me about life,
like, what would they say?
I think trees would tell you
growth is the most
important thing.
As long as you grow
a little bit,
you're doing as good
as you can do,
you know,
you're making progress.
♪ ♪
Today was a good day.
♪ River song's gonna
pull me through ♪
♪ The rest you can't save ♪
♪ Oh, my lord, take this soul ♪
♪ Lay me at the bottom
of the river ♪